vitesse sur autoroute réduite à 110 km/h
vous êtes favorable ou pas si on baisse
la Vitesse on réduit de 20% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le principe du coup c'est vrai que c'est
une mesure efficace pour le climat oui
mais voyez moi je prends pas tous les
matins ma voiture pour faire 30 km
vous me dites oui j'y suis favorable
voilà mais je pense que c'est important
sur des sujets comme cela de vérifier
qu'il y a aussi une adhésion des
Français alors il vous pourront compte
oui non 110 km/h alors à titre a quand
même pour savoir en Allemagne il n'y a
pas de limitation de vitesse dans les
autoroutes ou dans des zones urbaines
ils ont plutôt écolos et ils n'ont pas
mis en avant ce que met en avant la
Première Ministre Guillaume oui c'est
une excellente nouvelle pour la planète
ce qu'elle vit c'est moi
je vous dis franchement je veux pas je
veux pas indiqué la délation
parce que parce que franchement quand on
a des voitures qui qui consomment 57
litres au sens 57 litres 100 en
urbain et 70 litres sur l'autoroute il
me dit que c'est ma voiture déjà écouter
pas vrai vous êtes dedans qu'elle veut
c'est effectivement elle vise une baisse
des gaz à effet de serre de 20 % et ce
qu'elle veut c'est aussi inciter les
gens à ne pas forcément prendre leur
voiture pour des pour des trajets qui
qui ne nécessitent pas et c'est pour ça
que moi j'ai décidé de prendre le métro
tous les jours
je ne vous devriez voir honte de ton
chauffeur il me dépose au métro je
prends le métro
c'est la même empreinte carbone
alors vous vous dites NON
parce que la seule chose à qui ça va
faire du bien c'est au casse de l'État
il va y avoir des radars partout les
gens vont se prendre encore des PV je
pense qu'il y a vraiment un harcèlement
en France des gens qui utilisent leur
voiture et que la France est déjà la
bonne élève du monde sur le les
empreintes carbone donc voilà je trouve
que c'est démagogique
une réduction de la consommation de
carburant quand vous allez moins vite il
y a une réduction ça il y a un vrai
débat parce que c'est pas forcément vrai
parce que vous êtes plus haut dans les
tours et quand on roule à 120 ou à 130
km/h c'est pas toujours vrai pour tous
les modèles quand tu pousses la bagnole
les voitures qui font maintenant toutes
les bagnoles elles vont de sang à
200-210 230 les mêmes les petites
voitures alors non je suis pas d'accord
avec vous dites une grosse bêtise oui
suivant rappelez-vous il y a eu quand
même une grogne il y a pas si longtemps
lorsqu'on a baissé la limitation à 80
km/h là elle va s'attirer les foudres
des automobilistes parce que d'accord
l'idée c'est d'utiliser moins la voiture
mais qu'il y a au moins d'autres
alternatives et à ce jour les
alternatives elles sont pas si présente
que ça c'est un vrai problème le train
je voulais aller dans le sud le week-end
prochain il traîne complet pendant les
quatre cinq jours désolé vous nous
racontez votre vie en fait
l'alternative soit vraiment mise en
place
alors je suis désolé mais en vrai 130
c'est rapide je suis désolé quand c'est
un accident à 130 km/h c'est mortel donc
il y a pas de mal en fait à descendre à
Sandy je pense que ça va ça va tuer
personne au contraire donc d'un point de
vue écologique et surtout d'un point de
vue sécurité l'autoroute mais
la route en Allemagne il y a pas
d'imitation il y a moins d'action de
chez nous en Allemagne mais moins que
nous on vue de la conduite alors
peut-être des Français et bah il faut
les responsabiliser et c'est pas un mal
de dire bah ok vous allez baisser si ça
aide l'écologie et en plus ça aide la
sécurité mais quel est le problème
de faire c'est à dire que le peu de
plaisir quoi encore les gens d'avoir une
belle bagnole ou d'avoir d'autres trucs
c'est la vitesse c'est la vitesse
autorisée par temps de pluie et 130 donc
ça veut dire quoi ça va être 110 et
partant de plus on va rouler à 90 sur il
faut juste que les gens apprennent à
conduire soit sur les bonnes fines et ne
bloque pas les fils de gauche et
effectivement on rappelle une chose
c'est qu'il la limitation de vitesse en
Allemagne il y a moins d'accidents
alors je vais vous répondre ce que vous
avez tout à l'heure on s'en fout de
l'Allemagne en fait ici il y a des morts
il y a peut-être plus de morts justement
rien à voir ça n'a rien à voir avec le
nombre de morts c'est juste non ça n'a
rien à voir tu regardes dangereux
c'est les gens qui conduisent sans
perdre mais c'est les gens
qui excusez-moi
ça va faire un tollé ça plus le plus le
contrôle technique des des motos plus ah
oui la grande nouvelle de Hidalgo c'est
que maintenant il y aura des il y aura
des des PV pour le stationnement des
motos pourquoi pas mais ceux qui ont des
trois roues c'est à dire 90 % des gens
qui font qui prennent un scooter ils
vont être considéré comme des voitures
ça ça arrive ça alors ça c'est un vrai
scandale c'est qu'après ce quinquennat
très compliqué est-ce que ça ça fait
partie d'une des priorités du
gouvernement voilà c'était une mesure
qu'elle avait annoncé précédemment la
question est va-t-elle la remettre ça il
y a 2 ans